as a matter of fact
if you go to my channel right now i'll
release this got my skydiving video
i got a skydiving video you're gonna
release it right now exclusively for our
viewers
sure why not it's matt cox and inside
true crime
subscribe i'm gonna do right now i'm
gonna release the skydiving video
that's a good idea that's a great idea
sending a little exclusive
bonus weird no you have to pay
you don't even have to knock
but where's my view videos i'm going
into my
[Music]
chocolate pudding all right let's see
unlist public
save wow
unreal wow [ __ ] bird
the licker's talking oh look at him
matt cox going skydiving with a mask on
damn did you have to wear a mask when
you were skydiving
nice no just in the plane up you know
you'd take it off obviously
here bro that's the worst when you got
it when you go right up to that
door and then do you know what the horse
is you just got another five
you know what the worst is from kyle
roberts he sent you five extra [ __ ] yeah
he said he left the message in the chat
in the thing you know what the worst is
the worst is watching the guy in front
of you jump
because you see him go woo just he's
gone you're like
yeah and then you and then they just
jumped out of a plane
i have no desire to go skydiving are you
serious never
great look at that bro it looks fine
it looks cool listen i went with the
doctor the doctor's got his own stuff
his own
shoot he's he's jumped like like a a cup
okay i think he's
jumped like do you think the doctor
could give you hair implants while
skydiving oh my god
i mean could you imagine doing a hair
implant operation while skydiving
and but they're so sturdy they don't
come out while you're skyping you want
subscribers matt
oh yeah there you go make that [ __ ]
happen
all right you're all right yeah all
right so what did kyle say he said he
left it
in the paypal message he wants a special
message special message what
what who wants matt to go skydiving
while getting a hair implant from the
doctor
he just put okay that's pricey i mean
that's
that's seven grand for the hair couple
hunter for the plane jump
i mean you're talking eight grand now
easy eight grand and then you gotta pay
us
like a couple you gotta film to film it
yeah
you guys are something else man what the
hell that's all the time is anybody
is it what does your probation officer
know you went skydiving
what's the jurisdiction up there
i'm still in the middle district
i'm pretty sure so if you went like like
50 miles offshore out into the
international waters would you be
allowed to hang out with amadeo
or hang out with other felons yeah but
if you're in an international waters are
you allowed to just like he's probably
not even going to go out there
he's saying well i don't see what i'm
supposed to let me see
no message let me see it matt cox not
allowed in international waters
first of all i'm not allowed i'm not
allowed to leave the country oh he just
sent you his address
i mean you're leaving the state at that
point you're leaving the nation yeah
yeah so that's his address nowhere let's
write him a nice little note
draw him a little picture so another
hundred goddamn
doctor two another hondo from the dock
another oh
no it's not to him doc thank you doc no
200
to the blimp it says the doctor comes
through for matt cox
what are you doing stop sending money to
him sending money to him
what are you doing you made five grand
the last podcast this guy's
loaded i know you're telling everybody
not to send money to me
it's not sending the money to you you
are he's sending it to me
i think he knows how to send it to you
matt he sent you get like four grand the
last broadcast
he probably he did not will you stop
saying that it's you keep raising the
figures how much money did you make the
last podcast we did
i honestly i don't recall it was so much
he couldn't count because
there was a comma in the number okay
that's all that matters so i'm gonna
choose a comma
kyle to
your partner in crime
secret i want my book signed too he said
he wants
a picture of danny with a micro penis
and a rat face
who said that most wanted
okay give him all the cheese yeah
is there hold on matt after you sign
this i got a question for you
a really important question okay
all right what's the difference between
a snitch
and a rat what the [ __ ] what is this a
planned question
was the difference i don't know what
what did uh what did uh morgan freeman
say
it doesn't matter what morgan freeman
said i only care about what matt
cox says snitching a rat i don't think
there's a difference at all
really yeah i don't see a difference at
all
why didn't you say you went in a podcast
in la and
you got you got you got no you got in a
really fresh heated argument it actually
wasn't a heated argument
because it was awkward what was it what
would you call it it was
awkward because the guy was 300 or 290
pounds and probably
close to six foot tall and he was
extremely animated and
it could have gone bad could have gone
bad for me but it didn't
so what happened survived what did he
have to do oh he got super upset
i mean he saw he told me he knew with my
story yeah i know your story i know your
story
and you you admit it that you s you were
a snitch yeah i [ __ ] ratted on
everybody i [ __ ] could think
and your words you said you cut
everybody's throat you could
everybody's third i could yeah could
give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] them what was that quote that you
said vodka earlier what
the was it the the guy the general
whatever what's his name they said
amadeo yeah
there was a quote in the book that oh
yeah yeah oh uh be polite and thrax the
whole village
be professional and have a plan to kill
everyone you meet
wow that's uh general james
mad dog mattis james mattis
why do i know that name you know he was
in front of congress a few times
uh he was running uh i think he was the
military he he was the general who was
running i want to say afghanistan
during the surge i believe i could be
wrong yeah he looks like a green
rectangle covered in metals whenever you
see him on
a green rectangle yeah he's like
you know that kanye no this is like army
suit it's so
square like the roblox he looks like
kanye west and little pump in that video
i love it video i love it video but like
in military fatigue because he has so
many medals they had to expand
holy jacket
jesus what are you what are you reading
right now i mean i'm just
okay for people listening that don't
aren't watching matt's on his phone just
scrolling
i and he's saying things like uh
i'm saying there's just a bunch of i got
a bunch in the last three minutes four
minutes i've got a bunch of uh
paypals no oh no i wish she's going
through his youtube comments yeah just
comments
just comments good comments that's cool
cox i used to
i used to damn the doctor still scammer
doctors coming through again another
hundo
another
what does the doctor do why is he out
here splurging is he actually a doctor
um matt cox becomes what matt cox
becomes marcus shrinker i don't know
what that one is
he's calling you a liar wasn't there
another comment too that you said was
really interesting about your feet and
shoes and
what you think people okay so let's go
back to the snitch rat question
why because you think it's gonna bring
in some uh viewers what is it
i think it's interesting i want to know
so how did it go when
you said the guy was really animated he
was really intimidating why was he so
upset
he was upset because he's a pen guy
right so he robbed the bank
so the problem who robbed a bank um the
guy who's hosting this podcast that you
were on
yes okay and he's like an ex-con podcast
doing a true crime podcast or something
yeah he does it's supposed to be fresh
it's like you're fresh out of prison
okay and it's like what are you doing
now
okay got it so he says uh you know okay
so what do you what did you do
and he said look you know you talked for
about 15-20 minutes about what you did
and we'll talk about what you did in
prison and what you're doing now it's
like all right it's cool
so we start talking we talk about i say
okay so here's what
you know here's what got me into prison
or got me locked up i started going
through the whole motions boom boom
boom boom boom he's like all right all
right all right and then we get to the
point where i say okay and then i got
arrested
they're basically going to give me 154
years they're saying if they stack it
they can give me 154.
but that probably wouldn't happen i'd
probably end up if i went to trial and
lose i'll get probably 32 years
i said well i mean i said i'm not
[ __ ] doing 32 years i said so my
my us attorneys are my sorry my public
defender says you know or you can
cooperate
everybody's already cooperated against
you this is just how it works
you know this is what's going on and i
was like okay i was like well what do
you mean what do you what
and oh you just gotta be interviewed by
him i said okay cool i'll be interviewed
so at that point
he's like he gives me the look
you're a snitch at that point yes now
he's realizing because you agreed to
cooperate
yeah he's like yeah and i went so i
and i realized that's when i realized oh
you don't
really know my story you've you've never
really seen my story
right right you're saying you have but
you haven't right and then i'm like
you just saw the views yeah he he maybe
watched 20 minutes or something
but he didn't see it and i realized i've
seen all the guys you've interviewed
you know yeah and i know that the guys
that he's interviewed
if they cooperated they skate right over
it
does that make sense yes he doesn't like
to talk about it no they of course
you're not going to say it who's going
to say that right these guys aren't
going to say that they went to a pen or
they went to a medium and they're
i you know i i sold this minute you know
if you start doing the math
it doesn't really matter i got caught
with this many kilos and this mini
and this and this all these guys and
this and this and this and yes so i did
10 years
you did 10 years yeah that's a [ __ ]
life sentence but they never he never
goes into any of that it's never
so i say so boom i cooperate and i said
but then huge ingredient
has to go into that cocktail to make it
be ten years right and so
he sits there and he goes well he gives
me this look and i went oh
i said oh i said that's right nobody
really says that do they they don't
and they don't admit that yeah and he's
like
you know he's kind of like well i i just
don't believe in that and i went
no i understand i said well yeah because
i didn't tell nobody i said no i
understand i said well you're unique
so and i keep trying i try to let's just
you know like
okay let's just keep going and he keeps
coming back to it
so you you you you told on people yeah
yeah
i'm like yeah everybody told on me i
said that's just the way it is that's
what everybody everybody's [ __ ]
ratting on each everybody oh i i
wouldn't tell a nobody i wouldn't tell a
nobody
i'm like yeah i understand but you're
you're unique and you're going to a pen
and you're not looking at 26 years
you're you're a guy from the street
you're going to a pen
you you say something you might get
killed they're not sending me to a pen
i can't go to p because he's like man if
you went to the pin i go yeah but i
didn't
because i can't go to a pin because the
truth is is that they don't send people
like me to a pin
right i'm i'm i go up and then i said i
go bro i'm a soft white guy
they're not going to send me to the
brain and then he was like because these
guys couldn't
dare admit that they're soft right it's
all about
just pure anger and toughness and
no weakness and this is a guy who he
tells
kids part of it is well what would you
tell kids and so he evens up saying to
me what would you tell kids and i went
i tell them not to commit crime and yeah
but i'm saying if they get caught i went
don't commit crime you won't get caught
you know what i'm saying if they did
you're telling me if they did
commit crime you're saying
read my super chats who the doctor he
wants to know how much has the doctor
contributed to the cox fund all together
in the last three months
it's not the cox fund the doctor wants
to know how much he's contributed
that's what he said yeah i don't i i
don't know it's significant he bought me
i've got a computer he's helped me with
the computer he's helped me with
the camera equipment wow
just awesome